going back to a topic we kind of
touched on let's talk about obscure
anime
sure great what do you want to talk
about what are some obscure anime titles
that you
really like
how are obscure i know joe's going to
the same thing it's time to fight right
i know joey's gonna say mononoke right
modern okay
i need to see that i think that's i
think that's one of the best
yeah
i'll say it's really obscure i've never
heard of it yeah right yeah mononoke is
i think one of the best horror anime to
be ever made yeah hands down like it's
it's like genuinely the only show that
actually creeped me out yeah and that's
very difficult to do because there's a
lot of
really [ __ ] mediocre horror anime out
there sure you know
would you say like legends of the
collective heroes is obscure because i
don't i don't know nowadays it would be
because yeah i've i've known like a lot
of people prior to the reboot maybe yeah
yeah because i know a lot of people
who've heard of legends of black heroes
but i hardly know anyone who's actually
watched it
you know all right it's one of those
shows where people put it on like
they're to watch this as like one of
these shows they have to watch and then
no one ever watches it like a
brotherhood yeah yeah
it's on the same level it's about
exactly that's that's a pretty obscure
show right this one that for me have you
any of you seen god awkward mr stain on
junk alley i have not was could you say
when did that come out
it's just staying in junk alley i think
like 2005 or something
jerry normally sometimes knows the
japanese yeah whatever i think it might
be okay
google it
i'm trying to i'm trying to figure out
what your baseline from would you say
bocarano is obscure
uh
i haven't seen book around i know what
it is yeah get one of my favorite shows
is that the one we were talking about
with the
kids
yeah yeah yeah this is one of my
all-time favorites yeah i would say that
cause yeah um did you google it it looks
bizarre it's like a cg
series of shorts is this that
let me see it got a mystery and john
kelly
mr stayed on junk alley yeah
i've never seen that what is this check
it out sometime it's hilarious this
looks like a video game
yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta show
this yeah
it looks like a pc game from like the
90s oh i see like the old the og
funimation like ordnance yeah no no
funimation put it out they didn't dub it
but uh what the [ __ ] yeah
it is how did you find this animal a
friend of mine was just like hey let's
watch this i was like what the [ __ ] is
this and it was
great like at first i thought it was
just gonna be like stupid yeah and it
kind of is but it's so
so weird and so entertaining like i
thoroughly
thoroughly enjoyed it right like it's
just the weirdest funniest like
that's it's surreal the problem with a
lot of obscure anime is that a lot of
them are not that great it's probably
it's probably the reason why they're
obscure as well like because like it's
really hard to find like a real diamond
in the wrath when it comes to anime
because now nowadays especially people
know about so many people are exploring
different ones watches everything yeah
that like now whenever an obscure show
does kind of pop out from under the
ground then people are going to start
talking about it i really want to watch
more of those you know when you see
clips of like they they people just post
like 30 minutes like amazing animations
from those like 80 ovs yeah yeah yeah
yeah you want to watch more of those
yeah
yeah because there seems to be so many
cool ovas dudes there are so many like
80s and 90s ovas where it's just like i
didn't think 120 frames per second anime
existed until i saw the 90s
i really want to watch some of those but
i'm just like where the [ __ ] do i even
begin but even those even those like
obscure 90s ovas like back then in like
the early 2000s they were like
like you know like if you talk about
like jenna cyber or something right or
like violence jack where it's like no
one [ __ ] watched those back in the
day but now they're like so [ __ ]
obscure that people are talking about it
again and now they're like more talked
about them before so it's like because
you know i mean i wouldn't say genocide
is a good show necessarily it's violent
as [ __ ] that's probably the reason why
it's been talked about but like yeah a
lot of a lot of problems with the
obscure shows is that like most of them
in my opinion are like a five out of ten
and that's why no one wants to talk
about it but also it's just like it's
really interesting just to watch that
like kind of like ova period where it
just seemed it it felt underground you
know like where it just felt like anime
went through this like edgy teen phase
where just like let's make everything as
violent as [ __ ] possible yeah i
watched it i i went on like i remember
going on like a binge of like these like
90s and 80s ovas when i was in my i'm 14
and this is deep era and it was the best
but even though even though a lot of the
shows were so [ __ ] just like in on the
grander scale of things it's just like
yay blood violence sex woo
yeah
well like
i was i was gonna say like stuff like
even like the original devil man was
like obscure until he got the remake oh
no one had heard of devil man basically
before he got remade
huh well i mean it's also extremely old
it was like made in the 60s or 70s i
think yeah yeah yeah i was gonna ask do
any of you are any of you like me and
like vlog every anime you've ever
watched or not i i did for a while like
my anime list yeah yeah yeah i did for a
while until it just
i don't know i i i stopped doing it it
was an achievement after a while i got
like
yeah kind of like kind of like gamified
watching anime for me and then i didn't
really like that because sometimes i
love gamifying everything in my life i
love it the board game guys
i've ever ever watched
yeah because like it got to a point
where i would start like finishing anime
just so i could put it on the list yes
yeah yeah
like i was like i don't enjoy this
like why am i finishing this yeah i
literally am watching like wasting hours
of my life to finish a show just so i
could put it on my [ __ ] just so i can
talk about it for like two minutes of
the video yeah right yeah it wasn't
worth it and then i found out they were
just like like ruining my enjoyment to a
lot of shows so i stopped doing it and
i'm sorry to hear that but that's the
exact opposite with me oh really right
that's why i watched glenda after school
i was like i gotta watch it just uh yeah
and honestly i'm you know for me i get
it because you know time is limited
right yeah yeah i'm just a nerd who just
likes doing this and like
if i had because there was actually a
period where
i would drop shows really fast like
maybe in like my teen years or whatever
like early 20s like i was like ah this
is boy i'm going to stop oh it's three
episodes of boy i'm going to stop right
yeah and i just i kept dropping stuff
over and over and over again i was like
okay i'm gonna start like finishing
stuff even if i start hating it i'll
hate watch it to the end right yeah yeah
and like that well we're talking a lot
about clemat
i think you know revisiting you're going
into it after like you know a 14-year
gap or whatever yeah i think the first
like
eight episodes kind of suck like they're
not very good [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean i'm
gonna say that that literally put me off
clan ad yeah it's very it's very slow
i could tell like they were trying to
pull my heart strings i'm like no yeah
she's awful yeah and then they bring her
back and she's just awful but uh yeah
but then i because i stuck with it and
watched it like in the last 10 were like
really good i was like yeah i'm glad
that i like stuck with it yeah which is
kind of tying back to like the whole
reviewing thing yeah um
going back to like obscure
obscure [ __ ] so there was have you seen
have you seen tonkatsu dj akitaro yeah
that one's great that's a great show is
that obscure though because like do you
know what that is i'm gonna search
because like they made a lot of memes of
that i remember that show yeah the
because that's such a memey show yeah
yeah so it's like i remember at one
point what is this show
it's a tongue it's a guy who
works at a tonkatsu restaurant okay and
he's like i want to make him a dj and he
starts applying the skills
that he learned through making tonkatsu
into djing it's it's one of the weirdest
shows oh i have seen this one i have not
finished it but i have i have watched it
yeah okay okay that's really weird
this is like i i noticed like you find a
lot of obscure shows i guess through
like the early 2000s era yeah where i
because like i i think
after around like i think it's around
2016 2017 everyone just started watching
everything yeah but there's this like
magical golden period which is between
like it's between the 90s end of the 90s
ova era yeah like the golden age of the
mid-2000s yeah early 2000s there's just
so many [ __ ] shows where it's just
like what the [ __ ] yeah yeah because
there was like a lot of anime being
produced back then compared to like you
know say like the 90s and everything
like that but because of how the
internet was we just didn't have access
to every show like we did now so if like
fan subbers just didn't choose to sub it
then you just wouldn't hear about it at
all yeah and i guess like a lot of the
shows you're saying now just come it
just comes from that like comes from
that lost era god it feels weird to call
it a lost era
early 2000s oh my god
see i'm just looking at my
is is this is this your hobby just like
to just like find
your anime to like talk about talking
about it you know yeah i mean conor can
attest like when we met at um the anime
awards
it was like you me uh like miles and
like a couple of people just like you're
getting out of the lobby just talking
about anime just like have you seen this
or do you know this i
fell out in my depth pretty fast
yeah yeah i know that one yeah i know
that one then they said to my shows and
i'd get another one and i okay well i
don't wait
what the [ __ ] that was just like crazy
though yeah i mean yeah
everyone had like different levels of
anime knowledge but yeah yeah yeah
everyone was there said something sort
of to do with anime yeah yeah yeah so
it's really interesting it's like going
down like the anime iceberg you know
it's yeah it's like where where are you
on the iceberg yeah my my
main memory of that was just you just
playing love life in the corner while
everyone was just like awkwardly sitting
there but all you could hear is
and this guy is just like
and everyone's like
oh my god yeah what award did you
present at the anime awards i can't
remember me yeah
i don't remember
did you just turn it off
do you remember yours
on yours
i remember best i think i did best
comedy i think i did
best girl
best girl oh yeah you did you did how
how was that anime awards because i was
sad i didn't get i didn't get to go to
that one it wasn't really fun right i
mean john yeah we went to chicago
we went to mcdonald's yeah you got to
see like the crunchyroll
yeah we went to the control office yeah
yeah very fancy uh i remember yeah we
went to the really sketchy mcdonald's in
san francisco that's right yeah why
because uh because it was after
the
after the party
and so we were [ __ ] hungry yeah it
was like 11 p.m we were really hungry
and that's crazy on british slang yeah
that's right we're going through like
differences and stuff
yeah and we went to this mcdonald's that
was really really sketchy
yeah yeah like no windows it was like
really dimly lit it was really [ __ ]
weird yeah yeah yeah everyone who came
in was a character
gta or like a gta character yeah it's
just just downtown l.a yeah yeah
san francisco's scarier than l.a i think
sometimes really yeah why because like i
hear stories from like some of the [ __ ]
melin says and i'm like there's no way
this is a thing
is la scary or san francisco they're
both the same i don't think either is
particularly scary
maybe it's a farm person maybe yeah i
think both are pretty scary yeah okay
yeah to me la is like it's intense yeah
yeah i get it now when melin says like
you need to be alert like constantly
because like in japan you just like
[ __ ] zonk out okay when you're in
[ __ ] japan then you know like yeah
yeah you're fine like yeah yeah i mean
have any of you been to like i don't
know like baltimore or detroit or okay
are you you're from michigan right from
michigan yeah so like like i've been to
detroit and you know uh uh my wife grew
up in maryland so i've been to like
outside the inner harbor baltimore like
right those are areas that i'm like this
can be a little what is it like what's
the experience like over there uh
there's definitely areas where like we
shouldn't walk through here
because i think about that about l.a i
just think it's interesting yeah yeah
yeah because i think you should i would
not feel safe downtown especially but
downtown is disgusting but yeah yeah
right
in general yeah yeah
safety is a
relative right safety
safety is relative where you come from